[Music]
the cast of peaky blinders has featured
and tragically lost some true Legends
here are some of the actors from the
series you may not know passed away the
late Carl Shields might not be a name
that py blinders fans immediately
recognize but he played a key role in
the show's very first season he
portrayed Irish Republican Army member
Ryan who approaches Tommy with his
cousin to make an offer for the machine
guns a Blinder stole we'd pay good
money you have good money we have the
collections from the pubs born in Dublin
Shields was a huge presence in the Irish
live theater scene for years years
working in all manner of Productions as
both an actor and director he earned
many accolades over the course of his
life including a 1999 Award for best
actor at the Dublin theater Festival one
of his most prominent roles was that of
Robbie Quinn in the Irish soap opera
Fair City whom he played for nearly 200
episodes sheals passed away in his sleep
in July 2019 at the age of 47 Jeremiah
Jesus has got to be one of the most
beloved pey blinders characters even
though screen time is relatively limited
Street Preacher War veteran and honorary
peaky Blinder Jeremiah always seems to
show up when he's needed the
most God says he don't deal with small
he sir good man it's hard to imagine
anyone other than the late Benjamin
Zephaniah playing Jeremiah though he
appeared in other TV shows zephaniah's
artistic Pursuits transcended acting he
was a musician a poet and an outspoken
critic of English imperialism after the
death of Reay Superstar Bob Marley
Zephaniah was the first new singer to
record with his old band the Whalers he
also hosted a concert for Nelson Mandela
in 1996 in 2003 zephani I was offered a
prestigious OB e or order of the British
Empire but rejected it decrying the
United Kingdom's extensive history of
slavery and colonialism I've been
writing to connect with people not to
impress governments and monarchy
Zephaniah died of a brain tumor in
December 2023 at the age of 65 according
to a post made on his official Instagram
account his wife was by his side when he
passed in pey blinders Tim Woodward
played Lord suckerby A Member of
Parliament Accused by Tommy Shelby of
Despicable crimes in season 5 it may
have only ever appeared in a single
peaky blinders episode but Woodward had
an impressive career that spanned the
stage film and television he's probably
best remembered as the star of wings a
BBC War drama from the 1970s but he
appeared in dozens of movies and TV
shows over his career in November 2023
Woodward died of cancer at 70 years old
he survived by his wife Amanda and his
five children the acan world lost a true
Titan when Helen MCCC died of breast
cancer in April 2021 she was only 52
years old across her career mccy built a
reputation as one of the best actors of
her era in between critically acclaimed
turns on stage she worked on a ton of
major TV series and films including the
Harry Potter franchise Penny Dreadful
and Hugo among many many others but of
all her roles none stands taller than
that of Polly gray on pey blinders for
much of the show Polly is practically a
dual protagonist with Tommy providing a
veteran voice that can stand up to him
and give counsel when he leads the
family astray every scene where mccy
gets to take up space as Polly and there
are a lot of them is a high point I will
wear high heels so you can hear my
Approach on the couble stone and have
time to repent after her death series
Creator Steven Knight said Helen was one
of the great actors of her generation
she was so powerful and controlled and
this is so
sad